dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jean affair before we
start it is important to emphasize that
this paper is not using neural networks
not so long ago in 2015 the news took
the world by storm researchers were able
to create a novel and neural network
based technique for artistic style
transfer which had quickly become a
small subfield of its own with in
machine learning the problem definition
was the following we provide an input
image and a source photograph and the
goal is to extract the artistic style of
this photo and apply it to our image the
results were absolutely stunning but at
the same time it was difficult to
control the outcome later this technique
was generalized for higher resolution
images and instead of waiting for hours
it now works in almost real-time and is
used in several commercial products Wow
it is rare to see a new piece of
technology introduced to the market so
quickly really cool
however this piece of work showcases a
handcrafted algorithm that only works on
a specialized case of inputs text-based
effects but in this domain it smokes the
competition and here the style transfer
happens not with any kind of neural
network or other popular learning
algorithm but in terms of statistics in
this formulation we know about the
source text as well and because of that
we know exactly the kind of effects that
are applied to it kind of like a before
and after image for some beauty product
if you will this opens up the
possibility of analyzing its statistical
properties and applying a similar effect
to practically any kind of text input
the term statistically means that we are
not interested in one isolated case but
we describe general rules namely in what
distance from the text what is likely to
happen to it the resulting technique is
remarkably robust and works on a variety
of input-output pairs and is head and
shoulders beyond the competition
including the state-of-the-art neural
network based techniques that is indeed
quite remarkable I expect graphic
designers to be all over this technique
in the very near future this is an
excellent really well written paper and
the evaluation is
of high quality if you wish to see how
one can do this kind of magic by hand
without resorting to neural networks
don't miss out on this one and make sure
to have a look there's also a
possibility of having a small degree of
artistic control over the outputs and
who knows some variant of this could
open up the possibility of a fully
animated star transfer from one image
Wow and before we go we'd like to send a
huge shout out to our fellow scholars
who contributed translations to our
episodes for a variety of languages
please note that the names of the
contributors are always available in the
video description it is really great to
see how the series is becoming more and
more available for people around the
globe if you wish to contribute click on
the cogwheel icon in the lower right and
the subtitle slash CC text thank you so
much thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]